the comparisons are out there and
they're never going to stop
um
kind of me pat and and desean are kind
of all grouped together because we're in
the same draft class drafted in the
first round and um and all that but
there's no do-overs we are where we are
our careers are going in different paths
and and they will for the rest of time
and they're always going to be compared
against each other so it's just kind of
just the nature of the beast but
i'm in competition with myself just
trying to be the best version of me go
out there and win games for chicago
bears and
it's just something that i can't control
that's mitchell trubisky the bears
quarterback he'll be facing patrick
mahomes for the first time on sunday
night football on nbc and look it's not
trubisky's fault that that comparison is
there he didn't trade up from three to
two to draft himself the bears did and
the bears are the ones who deserve the
criticism that they made that move
instead of standing pat or even trading
down a few spots to get mahomes or
deshawn watson but trubisky's going to
be the guy chris who's always
feeling like he's the one who's the
target of that comparison and ultimately
criticism yeah no it's tough and it's
not fair to mitchell trubisky you're
right i mean hey listen the the people
that deserve that criticism are ryan
pace he's the one that made that choice
there and uh yeah it shouldn't be on
mitchell trubisky you know no it doesn't
look like at this point that he's ever
gonna be deshawn watson uh or patrick
mahomes it's not gonna happen all right
but it still doesn't mean he's not
capable of winning football games and
bringing your team to where it needs to
go now the question remains we don't
know where he's gonna go i mean yeah
right this was an inconsistent year and
can they win and and really do something
you know as far as making playoff runs
in a super bowl one with mitchell
trubisky i don't know the question is
out there i felt more confident
certainly after last year than this year
where it's been all over the place and
there's been more bad than good uh and
you know there they got their work cut
out with him as far as continuing to
develop him and matt and eggy and
getting the right pieces around him
it's match-up draft time a thursday
tradition during football season and the
new tradition to determine the first
pick the trivia question chris has
today's for me if i get it right i get
the first pick go oh i have it hold on
i'm pulling up my here we go sorry i
forgot here we go i only spent 10
seconds explaining it to give you time
you should have had that light bulb
flash when i started i'm thinking about
matchups and football here i mean i'm
just trying to do my job here we go tom
coughlin was fired as you know uh of the
v as the vp of football operations as
the jaguars coach he took the team to
the afc championship game in their
second year of existence who did the
jaguars lose to
in that afc title game and who was the
opposing coach
i mean
they lose
new england patriots and the coach was
bill parcell i mean are you kidding me
stats are you kidding me about that
question it's about time are you kidding
me it's about time i mean you might i
thought that question there for a second
was gonna go what's that thing that
everybody plays with on the football
field the quarterbacks throw it and the
running backs hold it when they're at oh
a football holy crap was that easy geez
it's about time i get an easy question
all right i'm going to start with the
match-up that i wish would have come
earlier in the year when both teams were
alive but one of them is still alive and
the guy who knows a thing or two about
playing for the steelers has a chance to
beat the steelers and knock them out of
the playoffs potentially and that's
le'veon bell the jets running back
against that steelers defensive front
seven that's the match up to watch there
are some jets fans that we know very
well who are confident the jets can
actually beat the steelers and it seems
like every week the steelers are the
inferior team but except against buffalo
and against cleveland and against a few
other teams they've found a way to be
the better team by scoring more points
le'veon bell is going to be fired up for
this one and if adam gase is smart he
will use bell early often and repeatedly
because bell is going to be driven to
stick it to the steelers well he will be
driven and you want to run the football
on the steelers a little bit so you can
you know you don't let that front four
and that front seven and some of the
exotic things the steelers defense do
when you're passing the ball too much
that's the that's that's what's
dangerous about the steelers i mean you
said it you know the steelers listen the
way their offense is they're not gonna
blow anybody out that's not gonna happen
so i'm with you there that's going to be
an interesting match up all together and
i do think the jets you know keep that
game very close no doubt about it i mean
give the edge of the steelers but i
think it will be close all right i'm
going with the saturday match up mcveigh
versus shanahan uh to me that's i'm
excited to watch that you know you know
just because of the the history of the
two for one kyle shanahan was down there
as the quality control assistant in
tampa bay the guy that replaced him sean
mcvay mcveigh then goes on to work for
shanahan with the washington redskins
for a number of years in the shanahan
family uh shanahan moves on to get
another job mcveigh stays there becomes
the offensive coordinator gets a head
coaching job before kyle shanahan so i
just feel like some of the personal
competitiveness let alone this is a big
moment for both of these football teams
and the rams
they got a head coaching job in the same
cycle i did they both became i know but
mcveigh got it first i know i know well
because shanahan was still working well
i got it i'm just saying i'm just like
all right all right i mean that's really
i mean if mcv if mcvay thinks that he
has an edge over shanahan because he was
hired three weeks earlier because
shanahan couldn't be because the falcons
were still playing that's awfully damn
shallow well i don't i don't know if
anybody thinks that i'm just pointing it
out okay i'm just that's all i'm trying
to say you're awfully shallow all right
i am shallow that's great but either way
i i'm really pumped for the matchup
because of the personal history and the
importance to both franchises both
offenses kind of struggled last week and
it will be about some of their game
planning and little tricks they bring as
far as this week's scheme wise to uh to
go to as far as who wins the football
game now look i know sean mcvay's
grandfather was in the business but his
dad wasn't do you think that there's any
kind of edge any kind of attitude any
kind of resentment when you're a coach
who made it without dad helping you even
though kyle shanahan has done very well
on his own
you know we know how nepotism rules in
football do you think the guys whose
dads weren't coaches looked differently
at the guys whose dads were i don't know
necessarily uh it's such a family
business to begin with and i think
mcveigh is a pretty
you know smart thoughtful guy to realize
that he got in the business too because
of his grandfather i mean there's no
doubt about it him pulling strings that
way you know i'm sure he had a
relationship with gruden to get him into
that to get sean into that role there
and get him in the building so no i
don't i actually think with kyle
shanahan the fact that he worked for his
father hurt him in a lot of ways because
people didn't want to give him the
credit for some of the things they did
offensively with the washington redskins
they gave it to mike where it was really
mike letting kyle do his thing
and i think that came back to bite kyle
a little bit in the little in the butt a
little bit between him being under not
only shanahan but kubiak where people
gave those two the credit uh uh they
gave the credit to the head coaches
instead of kyle
all right next one for me a guy who
always gets the credit when the offense
does well coach andy reid the kansas
city chiefs taking on one of his former
pupils matt neggie yeah the head coach
of the bears on sunday night football
and i think andy reid is very smart
about holding things back from some of
his lieutenants and also studying very
carefully how they do their jobs while
with him so he will know if and when
he's doing his job against them and i
think andy reid will have the better of
this one but it'll be fun to watch first
time the two of them are coaching
against each other it was reed that gave
nagi the chance in philly after he'd
been out of football for years kind of
got into the business a little bit late
groomed him helped him get the job he
now has and now they get to square off
on sunday night so i'm looking forward
to seeing that yeah no that's gonna be a
great matchup i am too i mean there's a
lot of things that play there and and of
course chuck pagano's gonna have his
hands full with patrick mahomes and andy
reid um you know my next one i gotta go
to here is really
josh allen versus bill belichick uh you
know i kind of want to say brian dabal
who came from new england i want to add
him into this too
because he's the offensive coordinator
but more specifically josh allen versus
bill belichick you know hey josh allen
was just too loose and crazy the first
time around when the bills played the
patriots and his interceptions were were
the difference in the football game i
mean
the bill's lost by three points or what
six points and turned the ball over four
times in the football game you know so
that that just tells you they're capable
of playing close if josh allen can reign
it in
not try to force things don't let bill
belichick get into your head with crazy
you know defensive schemes and people
dropping here and whatever else take a
sack sometimes punt the ball that could
be the best thing you can do for your
football team because remember your
defense is going to give tom brady in
that average patriots offense a tough
time as well
my last pick comes from a sneaky great
game on sunday the new orleans saints on
a short week making the trip to
nashville to take on the titans titan's
still alive for the postseason chase in
the afc
saints in position potentially to be the
number one seed in the nfc sean payton
versus dean pease the defensive
coordinator of the titans who has shown
throughout the season that he can be
very creative remember it was that game
i think all the way back in week one
against the browns chris where when you
watched the film it was every coverage
imaginable that pease was able to use to
confuse and confound baker mayfield
right that is going to be the test can
dean p's come up with the right calls to
maybe anticipate where sean payton is
going to try to create an opening for
drew brees to make an easy throw that
results in a touchdown or a big gain
that's going to be a battle within the
battle what the new orleans offense can
do against the tennessee titans defense
and the lower scoring the game the
greater the chance the titans have of
winning it yeah definitely i mean i
think that will be a close game and
you're right dean p's and company they
well a little too much man-to-man but
they can do some creative things for
sure and hey let's not forget that that
titan's offense is capable of moving the
ball too uh i'm going watson and watson
and winston the w's at quarterback
watson and winston yeah i can't wait to
watch that football game for one but i
think the thing that where i look at
here where this matchup is fun to me is
both of these defenses are just not good
in past defense you know and i know
james winston doesn't have all his
weapons at his disposal but no evans no
godwin but still this game is going to
be won through the air by one of these
quarterbacks and who can make the most
you know big plays be the most
consistent learn you know limit
turnovers but i think we're gonna see
fireworks for sure in this football game
uh i think we're gonna see both teams go
back up and back down the field uh i
think ultimately desean watson with the
weapons he's got his disposal's got the
advantage there but i am excited to
watch that on saturday afternoon
see i had on my list another quarterback
matchup lamar jackson baker mayfield
number one pick last year and baker
mayfield number 32 picking lamar jackson
and a little rematch a little revenge
opportunity for the mvp and maybe some
resentment from baker mayfield because
lamar became the star that we thought
baker was going to be this year so i
thought about that when that just made
the fringes for me but you kind of sold
me on watson and winston
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports